[Music]
thousands of people at a mass gathering
violating kovid 19 protocol election
rallies and political events are in full
swing as coronavirus cases surge across
india fueled by the omicron variant
on the stage is new delhi's chief
minister who has now tested positive and
is being criticized as his government
imposes new restrictions
saturday or sunday there will be a
curfew on weekends which means saturdays
and sundays in delhi i appeal to people
not to step out during curfew
only step out if extremely necessary and
follow the curfew and stay in your home
work from home
the new rules come a week after the city
imposed in night curfew and also closed
down schools gyms and cinemas
now it's asking its employees to work
from home telling people to only step
out when absolutely necessary
india's financial capital is the hardest
hit schools like this one have now
reverted to online teaching for most
students
despite restrictions on gatherings
people have been flocking to beaches and
tourist hotspots across mumbai
it's a good decision to impose
restrictions in the state but the crowd
here today will only lead to more cases
of omicron it would have been better if
this decision was taken a bit earlier
and we would have been able to control
the spread
elsewhere crowds are staying away from
popular sites
this famous museum in the eastern city
of kolkata was almost deserted schools
and many businesses were closed
but some business owners facing
financial losses are questioning some of
the restrictions
places that get crowded like bars
restaurants and cinemas all of those are
open but only gyms spas and beauty
salons have been closed
gyms are for people's health and they
can help people during the pandemic
despite the rapid spread of kovite 19
hospital admissions remain low
but hundreds of healthcare workers have
tested positive sparking staffing
concerns
one of india's top hospitals has ordered
doctors to return from vacation and
prepare for an influx of patients
al jazeera new delhi